up next robert silvers moderates a panel
discussion on the current global
economic crisis taking part in the
discussion are George Soros author of
financial turmoil in Europe and the
United States
Paul Krugman author of end this
depression now Jeffrey Sachs who wrote
the price of civilization reawakening
American virtue and prosperity and
Edmund Phelps author of rewarding work
this is about two hours
good evening I'm Tom Campbell director
of the Metropolitan Museum and I'd like
to welcome our distinguished guests and
our audience to the Met this evening for
this important discussion at first
glance an art museum might seem like an
unlikely forum for a conversation like
this but in fact we are an institution
devoted to objects deeply connected to
history's economic forces throughout
history artistic production has been
linked to economic prosperity as
societies developed so too did artistic
output and patronage and our collections
are largely reflective of that dynamic
from the ivories of the neo-assyrian
empire dating as early as the 9th
century BC to the Egyptian temple of
zdenda created under the wealth of the
Roman Empire 800 years later from the
gold threads found in ancient Chinese
tapestries to the portraits in our
Renaissance portrait exhibition that
asserted the strength and humanist
ideals of 15th century Italy indeed our
galleries chart the rise and fall of
civilizations throughout history the
exchange and sale of artistic objects
has also been a crucial component in the
development of the trade routes around
the world the Silk Road for example or
the development of critical ports
Antwerp Venice and many others allowing
the abundant exchange of ideas and
resources by the beginning of the 1st
century AD merchants diplomats and
travelers could with some difficulty
cross the ancient world from the
Mediterranean to China and Japan in the
east
such trade routes were the communication
highways of the ancient world allowing
for the flow of religious beliefs
languages
customs and artistic styles you just
have to visit our Asian galleries for
example to see how the sculpture of
Gandhara modern-day Pakistan and
northern India was influenced by the
Hellenistic styles popularized by the
Romans if we briefly visit the
conditions of this museum's founding and
evolution you will also find an extra
pocket in inextricable link to the
economic circumstances of post-civil war
New York it was the idea of private
citizens to create this public art
museum and it was the fortunes built
from railroads and Industry that allowed
it to happen there would have been no
Egyptian excavations without the likes
of JP Morgan and certainly much thinner
collections here without the late likes
of Jacob Rogers a businessman who made
locomotives in Paterson New Jersey and
too in 1902 unexpectedly left the
Metropolitan $5,000,000 the equivalent
of hundreds of millions of dollars in
today's art buying terms when the Met
was founded in 1870 it did not own a
single work of art and its growth during
the late 19th and 20th century is a
reflection of America and New York's
economic prosperity across that period
today the Met is the largest truly
encyclopedic Museum in the world with an
annual gross operating budget of 300
million dollars we have the highest
attendance of any museum in the United
States just under five point eight
million people last year with an
audience that is 40 percent
international and an additional 50
million visitors on our website we have
the largest acquisition program of any
Western Museum spending 40 to 50 million
dollars annually with many times that
coming in the form of gifts and we
maintain the largest exhibition program
in the world with about 30 exhibitions a
year and the largest publication program
of any Museum in this year alone we will
produce 22 scholarly art history books
all this funded not by the government
but by private philanthropy benefiting
from a long-standing American
philanthropic tradition and critical tax
incentives introduced in 1917 today
nearly 90% of our annual operating
budget is privately funded in the past
17 years over 1 billion dollars has been
raised from private sources to support
our capital projects and endowment so as
I look to the future we have quite a
vested interest in the continuing
prosperity of the American economy and I
hope I'm gonna hear good news from our
panelists let me end by suggesting that
the Met is uniquely positioned to engage
in this sort of global dialogue in the
sort of global dialogue outlined for
tonight's program a large part of what
the net offers our national and
international audience is that it is a
lens to envision the future within the
context of history I see tonight's
program is very much part integrated
with that part of our mission and I'm
delighted to welcome the editor of The
New York Review of Books
Robert Silva twice staged to moderate
this critical discussion so with no
further ado gentlemen it's over to you
thank you
you know thank you Tom and thanks also
to the members of the Met staff and so
helpful in arranging this evening
we couldn't imagine a more congenial
place for this forum than the
Metropolitan Museum
it's the symposium on world economic
problems as it was brought to you not
only by the New York Review of Books and
the Met but also by our friends at the
very generous fruit board organization
in also which is often collaborated with
the review and supporting meetings such
as this one and I want to thank George
Soros for Danone donating copies of his
just published book which you have seen
on the tables outside and finally I want
to thank Simon head of Oxford who's been
the major organizer of this evening and
I should remind you that books by other
panelists will be available following
tonight's event now for this evening we
raised several issues with our
participants we thought of the
continuing problems of the euro and the
tightrope being walked in Greece as we
speak and the question of how the Euro
itself will fare as a common currency
without the european treasury or a
stronger constitution we thought
secondly of the seiki the shaky
situation of the United States since the
recession and how its problems of high
unemployment and stagnant income will be
affected by our political situation here
as well as the crisis in the eurozone
third we raised the question of the
Chinese economy which is functioned as
an engine of global economic growth in
recent years
how would respond if its chief export
markets in Europe and the u.s. remain
weak
finally hovering over all these issues
is a question of global warming and how
measures to deal with it could possibly
be integrated with the other economic
concerns I've mentioned now to deal with
these questions we have here I think a
remarkable panel of economic experts and
commentators in alphabetical order we
have Paul Krugman whose work we all read
in the New York Times he's been a
skeptical commentator both about the
direction of European austerity and
American fiscal policy he's won the
Nobel Prize he's currently a professor
at Princeton his most recent book is the
return of depression economics and the
crisis of 2008 now here we have next to
me Edmund Phelps he's professor at
Columbia won the Nobel Prize also in
2006 for his work on the relation
between short-run and long-run effects
on economic policy he's the author of
the book rewarding work how to restore
participation and self support to free
enterprise Jeffrey Sachs on my left is
the director of the Earth Institute at
Columbia which deals with such problems
as climate and environmental degradation
and poverty and disease and sustainable
use of resources he's advised many
governments he's the author of the book
the price of civilization finally and my
far left George Soros has written nine
books on globalization and the political
comedy economy of the United States and
the workings of domestic and global
financial markets I've already mentioned
his new book financial turmoil in the
United States
he's chairman of the Open Society
Institute and of the Soros management
fund and by now he's given away over
eight billion dollars to advance human
rights and public health and education
now
now to all these very distinguished
participants we've made it clear that
we're leaving it to them to arrive at
their own synthesis of the issues I've
mentioned and to select and give the
emphasis they want to the questions they
would single out each of them will speak
from 12 to 15 minutes I have here a
yellow card given me by Simon head and I
will wave it at each speaker approaches
two minutes before each speaker
approaches 15 minutes well then have
some talk among ourselves and for about
15 minutes or so and then we'll have
questions from the audience and now our
first speaker Paul equipment okay thanks
Bob couldn't resist you when you said
talked about Greece walking a tightrope
that's not how I see it I guess I said
I'm walking the plank okay and the
topics that Bob mentioned obviously it
seems to me obviously climate change
trumps everything else and if we don't
do anything about that none of the other
things we're talking about matters and
therefore I'm not going to talk about it
at all because it's sort of beyond me
here I I thought in these introductory
Mars I talked instead of that about
about the macroeconomics we are
suffering from it's it has become a
tired cliché but this is the worst
global slump since the Great Depression
and it's it's not as much less bad than
the Great Depression for a number of
countries as you might think here it's
not as bad by a long shot but that's
partly because we had a really terrible
Great Depression but in but it's still
plenty bad and in a number of other
countries it's actually is is as bad so
this is a really really terrible
economic crisis nowhere close to being
over so it was kind of almost
disheartening to see people reacting
with to last month's employment report
which was better than expected
as if okay well then that that's that's
solved because it's not that's it's
going to take reasonable estimate if
each month from now on is as good as as
January was we might be at full
employment by about 2019 so if this is a
we're very very deep in a hole we have
maybe begun a very slow Klein and of
course in Europe not even that Europe is
is almost certainly in recession again
so this is a very very bad situation but
I often think that the most important
thing to say about this is that although
it's uniquely bad for the past 70 years
it's not it's not unprecedented and it's
not basically mysterious that this is a
very if you like it's just sort of a
mega version of a quite standard
economic crisis that actually Ken Rogoff
on our site in a moment said in one
meeting that we're experiencing a garden
varieties of your financial crisis which
is the kind of thing only an economist
could say but it's true but it's deep
what we're going through is not is not
mysterious it's not something we I mean
obviously there are many details and
people didn't foresee it nobody foresaw
it and it's full extent but it's not as
if this is some mysterious unheard-of
unprecedented event and so Ken Rogoff
actually with Carmen Reinhart wrote a
very good book I disagree with some of
the things they've been saying lately
but they wrote a very good book which
had a wonderful title which was this
time is different
meant to be said with a sarcastic
intonation because in fact very rarely
is this time different and this time is
not different what we're facing is a
standard severe economic slump in which
the basic problem is that that people
are not spending enough to make use of
the economic capacity we have we have
workers the workers are are not you know
they may not have the ideal mix of skill
but they're not lacking in skills we
have productive capacity what we don't
have is enough spending the reasons
behind that are also at this point
fairly clear we had a binge of private
sector debt widespread private borrowing
both sides of the Atlantic are seen
monstrous housing bubbles and debt
bubbles on both sides the Atlantic
partly because of financial deregulation
partly because it had been a long time
since the last really severe economic
crisis and people get
and that's that's the behind in Minsky
story economic crises
bleahh breed caution which leads to a
long period of calm which leads to
complacency which leads to the next
crisis and and in a sense this was a
cycle we may have been fated to go
through but there's no inherent reason
why the adjustment why the hangover has
to be as bad as this and the the job of
the government when something like this
happens is to step in with fiscal
expansion and monetary expansion and
provide enough demand because no good is
done by allowing 13 million workers to
be unemployed you have a debt problem a
debt overhang it needs to be worked off
some of it needs to be defaulted on some
of it possibly inflated away but it
makes it doesn't help anybody to have
the economy producing a trillion dollars
a year less than it should be producing
to have vast numbers of workers who
could be doing productive things sitting
idle instead and so the job of policy
should be for the through government
spending through aggressive policy on
the part of the Federal Reserve and
counterparts abroad to minimize the
economic damage as we as we work our way
through this the consequences of past
misjudgments unfortunately we haven't
been doing that we've been doing a
certain amount of it automatically
that's why this isn't as bad as the
Great Depression probably the biggest
reason is simply that we have a much
larger government than we used to and
when the economy when the economy
collapses well the social security
checks keep going out and the Medicare
bills keep done being paid and that acts
as a great stabilizer on the economy but
in terms of actual effective policy we
had a woefully underpowered stimulus in
this country which was which has now
essentially faded out we've had
austerity programs both in in a number
of countries and in this country at the
level of state and local governments
forced on them which have actually done
nothing to so we've actually in some
ways exacerbated the downturn is to
fighting it why are we doing this for me
at least the most disheartening thing is
that we have a lot of analysis
you know we have 80 years of economic
thinking trying to understand these
things we have a a basic understanding
that's not too bad and when push came to
shove policymakers and a fair number of
economists just chuck the textbooks
right out the window and instead made up
their own rules and so they made up
stories about how governments would
actually improve the economy by slashing
spending the doctrine of expansionary
austerity because it would lead to an
increase in confidence which I've I
think my contribution to the to the to
the literature of this is the phrase
believing in the confidence fairy so
we've had when we've had no serious
governments believing basing their
policies on belief in the confidence
theory and we've had obviously we've had
political constraints as well but those
common part from from intellectual
confusion so it's been very
disheartening the the only thing I think
I can do in this country is to keep on
plugging and hope that when you turn it
around the Europeans have a special
problem overlaid on all of that which is
that they have set up an institutional
structure namely a single currency
without a single government that makes
things a lot worse they they do not have
a single government that can that
automatically in our case redistributes
resources to the most hard-hit regions I
think of the comparison between Nevada
and Ireland which actually look almost
exactly alike as long as you stay with
the statistics and don't look out the
window and it's terrible housing bust
terrible Verizon unemployment lots of
losses on loans but in Nevada the
retirement programs and the medical
bills of the elderly are paid from
Washington the the banks deposits are
guaranteed from Washington fair bit of
the loan losses are falling on us on
Washington based agencies so there's a
lot of automatic buffering of Nevada
which Ireland doesn't have and so
Ireland is in fiscal crisis on top of
everything else whereas Nevada it's not
good but but they don't have the same
kind of problems the Europeans are a
terrible mess because they they created
this thing the single currency without
actually with with almost a willful
disregard of the question of what
happens if something goes wrong and they
really are not prepared for it what I
would have said is that
what do they do the only way to make
this work would be to actually do the
kinds of things that we should be doing
in the US but more so that the European
Central Bank should be even more
aggressive than the Fed and that that
those European governments that can do
fiscal stimulus should be doing it which
is Germany and and a few others doesn't
seem to be happening although I will say
that since the European Central Bank
shifted from jean-claude Trichet to
Mario Draghi Draghi is doing more of
what needs to be done and I've actually
been very impressed by his subtlety he's
been able to stitute on the one sense
say no I will not buy sovereign debt the
ECB will not do that's not not we can't
do that but we will lend unlimited
amounts of money to the banks accepting
sovereign debt as collateral that has
been beautiful to see him actually say
one thing and do the opposite and if and
it was the right thing to do the I don't
think she's talking about China I'm
actually actually think I want to just
come back to to the broader issue right
now here's what someone who wants to be
wise says he sister and strokes his
chances well this is a long-run problem
you can't expect short-run solutions and
we need to work on the fundamentals and
you can't expect to quick recovery from
this which all sounds very wise and is
totally totally wrong
and extremely foolish very naive the
reality is that we have a yes we have we
always have long-run problems but right
now we have a short-run problem we have
a problem which is what John Maynard
Keynes he called it magneto trouble
electrical system we have a $30,000 car
with a bad battery and fix the damn
battery it's replacing it we could be
back we had a more or less full
employment economy just just five years
ago we could do that again we could do
it quite quickly if only we had the
political will and the intellectual
clarity and every argument that you see
people making right now about why we
can't do that about technology about
skills about globalization you go back
to the 1930s need to find people making
some version of the same argument you
can find articles from 1935 about how
even if there was a big increased demand
the US workforce know
has the skills to deal with modern
technology and we could never get back
to really full employment and then
wasn't even the war just the approach of
the war when the United States began
spending to prepare for the war between
1939 and 1941 before Pearl Harbor all of
a sudden we had a 7% increased
unemployment the equivalent to 10
million jobs right now and all of those
arguments were disproved even before
even before the Japanese planes dropped
their bombs we could do that again again
if only we had the political the
political will and the intellectual
clarity we don't but I think it's the
job of people like us hop on here with
this panel to at least try to supply the
intellectual clarity
and so now we have professor Edmund so
our country is suffering I think from
two basic intellectual failures in the
economic sphere first the country has
not learned how to combat structural
slumps many economists have not learned
how to recognize one policymakers are
fixated on tax rates differing only on
whether they ought to be raised that's
the party of austerity or lowered that's
the party of profligacy I think the low
level of this low level of discourse is
an indictment of economics departments
in America second and more important I
think our country lacks a moral basis
for renewal and reform of the economy
because it has failed failed so far to
obtain a consensus on the good life also
known as the American Dream and on
economic justice and I think this is an
indictment of universities there they're
mired in chic postmodern relevance
relativism they never never got behind
Nietzsche James and Bergson on the good
life and they're not really behind Rawls
Rorty and Habermas either on the first
failure the public discourse has been
polluted by those on the right who say
that the economy would be fine again if
we would stop violating conservative
precepts and talking up new violations
they do not grasp that taxes are
warranted to finance justifiable
subsidies and investments and to fund
justifiable future commitments those on
the Left see the economy is a productive
and indestructible apple orchard it just
has to be regulated more tightly to
smooth out the crop
and we have to address the inequality in
the distribution of the apples which
means ever more help for the middle
class more help with medicine with
housing with college tuition and
everything else to which the middle
class is naturally entitled now I know
our organizer was keen that we talk
about Greece so inspired by by his
interest I I'm starting with with with
Greece myself people see the fix that
Greece's in as a moral parable that is a
warning to the rest of the West but the
parable has flaws or mistakes in it
it's far too crude to lay the crisis in
Greece on an over large welfare state or
on pandering after the votes of public
employees Germany Holland and Sweden
have the lowest unemployment rates in
Europe despite huge welfare programs and
well-paid civil servants - they're saved
by their horror of under taxation there
is no such horror among the Greeks
Greece allowed its public debt and as
public outlays to soar in relation to
tax revenue so the correct moral to be
drawn here is spend what you like but
pay your bills on time now
Press reports tell us that ordinary
citizens and citizens in Greece did not
know of the now scandalous
underreporting of the under taxation the
reports say that the crisis results or
the implied that the crisis results from
the unpreparedness of the country to
determine how the costs ought to be
shared and the benefits adjusted tax
increases or rollbacks of civil service
pay or some give backs and pensions for
a while what everybody is at loggerheads
so I think the correct moral of this
story is do not keep the truth from the
public
we need openness transparency but has
nothing to do with the size of the
welfare state or pay for civil servants
both views leave us to believe that a
country that indulges for a long time in
deficit spending and the creation of
unfunded entitlements you know those
things that are claims on future tax
revenues that after indulging in those
things for a long time the country will
be fine again once it gets its public
debt entitlements under control even if
it suffers this short this is the
suggestion I think is public discussion
even if it suggests even if it suffers a
short recession resulting from the
increases in tax but tax rates or
cutbacks and government purchases that
that have to take place the way will
then be open to a
and fast recovery a Hollywood happy
ending even high debt high entitlement
countries such as Italy and France will
be okay I think this is precisely the
economic thinking from Ronald Reagan to
George Bush and Barack Obama when
employment sags
whatever the cause cut taxes and let the
deficits flow will grow out of the
public debt but what if the productivity
growth stops as it did in Italy in the
1990s and I think also in France
I forgot to look it up before I left the
problem is that increased wealth all its
wealth that is created by the deficits
on top of the wealth that already
existed all this wealth finances
non-work uses of one's time and the
traditional taxes levied to service that
debt do not reduce what this bloated
wealth they reduce wages none of tax so
you get both a fall of net wages in the
numerator and a rise of wealth in the
Nunda now in the denominator and that's
that's bad it's not all I have to say
about unemployment but it's an important
thing to focus on Italy and France have
a big problem here they have long been
high savers amassing levels of private
wealth that are huge relative to their
wages
now all those budgetary deficits in
times past the taxes that Italians of
the French did not have to pay that
would have offset the wages and the
benefits paid out by the state
all those budgetary deficits have added
a lot of paper wealth
to the true will to the true private
wealth of the Italians in the French as
as measured by what they could consume
over the future as a result the supply
of labour to the economy
there was labour force participation
rates are going to remain depressed for
years as Nationals work off their wealth
or productivity growth gradually does
the job pulling up wages very strongly
the question here in America is whether
the country faces the long same slog
that I believe Italy and France face
over the future the bright side is that
over the past ten years Americans net
wealth slowed in tandem with a slowing
of productivity and wages so net wealth
of households as a ratio that means net
of liabilities net wealth of households
as a ratio to their disposable income
stood at the same 515 percent in 2010
that it was at in 2002 not a change not
a dimes worth of change nothing like
Italy where there's been an explosion of
wealth and France even worse so that's
good by this token we should be enjoying
now the the 2003 unemployment rate here
and now in 2012 rather than the what we
the unemployment rate we actually which
is eight point five percent of course we
know that lots of other things have
intervened but that's where the analysis
is going at the moment but then then
comes some bad news we have to reckon
with people's entitlements
people's people's wealth consists not
only of their private wealth but what I
like to call their social wealth the
wealth created by a stroke of the pen by
the government a calculation by Mary
Meeker a New York financial economist
finds that Americans entitlements net of
Social Security funding which isn't much
added up to sixty six trillion dollars
at the end of 2010 that's the present
discounted value of all the entitlements
that's more than 500 percent of
disposable income so now we have the 515
trillion dollars of private wealth and
on top of that we have 66 trillion
dollars of entitlement the wealth so I'm
sorry 515 percent of disposable income
so that would be if disposable income is
around 12 billion then 550 was over 60
so the private wealth is about 60
trillion and now with the stroke of a
pen or several strokes of several pens
the government has created 66 trillion
dollars with the social wealth and of
course it's common knowledge that
entitlement spending has been exploding
in recent years so that 500 percent of
social what social wealth as a percent
of disposable income must have shown a
huge increase compared to the level back
in 2002 so when you come down to it
wealth considerations do not point to
getting back to the unemployment rate we
had in 2002 it's much worse than that
we're in for a slump of regulation
Reinhart Rogoff length a dozen years or
so and budgetary deficits in the present
day decade well had another trillion
dollars to miss well what Americans to
do very briefly I have ideas about what
I would do if I were a philosopher King
I would aim to rehabilitate and reform
the economy its institutions and its
economic culture reform it for the
generation of innovation economic
dynamism is the elixir of economic life
the conception of crude Keynesianism
that by pushing the right buttons we can
dial the employment level we want
handouts to increase consumer demand and
if that doesn't work construction
projects to employ strong back labor
that's discredited by cross-section
studies of what explains high employment
and low employment among nations what
this dynamism would require what getting
it would require our efforts on a broad
fund front to encourage more
entrepreneurship and finance in start-up
companies and to encourage students and
young graduates to vote themselves -
imagining creating and exploring to the
extent that these efforts succeeded
these efforts would lift job
satisfaction and employee engagement and
raise employment - now while dynamism is
crucial we want dynamism with economic
justice with what I call economic
inclusion that doesn't mean social
inclusion which is about income it means
throwing people into the economy which
is the core activity of society
preferably into the business sector of
the modern economy where new ideas for
new products are conceived developed and
tested and it means pulling up wages in
the lower echelon of the labor force the
main instrument here must be a
government
program of graduated subsidies to
companies for their employment of
low-wage workers and my book rewarding
work with Robert Silver's Connie
mentioned estimated that the cost of a
plan big enough to make up a big
difference was close to two percent of
the gross domestic product I know Jeff
Sachs wants to use that 2% in his ways
but but I think this is a terribly
important way to use it
this vision as many of you know that is
laid out is a fusion of the best part of
Friedrich Hayek and the best part of
John Rawls understood and slowly made
more and more clear that a modern
economy is an organic thing that is
capable of imagination and creativity
not the mechanical thing of crude
Keynesianism I argue in my recent work
that to be a part of that system is for
most people the only way by which they
can expect to have a a good life a life
of exploration and discovery and
engagement and use of their mind and
their their emotions
Rawls understood that economic justice
involves not just transfer payments to
people to permit them to consume more or
to work less or not work at all that
wasn't at all what he meant by economic
justice for Rawls economic justice
justice involves modifying the
distribution of the rewards from work in
the society's economy to favor the less
advantaged as much as possible
interestingly in his last decades Hayek
allied himself with Ross's perspective
so I'm hoping that with time the country
will become persuaded that this is the
way to go that this is the only way by
which we can get back to an economy with
the excitement and the sense of
challenge in progress that we once knew
until a couple of decades ago thanks a
lot
and now Jeff says thanks very much let
me add another another thought to the
discussion we do not have a global
economic crisis not even close we of
course have a mess in the United States
we have a mess in Greece we have the
crisis in Spain we have a crisis in some
of the other countries of southern
Europe we have a crisis in Ireland but
even within Europe there is no crisis in
Germany now unemployment is at very low
levels compared to the last couple of
decades there's no crisis in the
Netherlands in Denmark in Finland Sweden
Norway Northern Europe is doing rather
well low budget deficits rather high
employment very high prosperity trade
balance or surplus and if we look
farther beyond the North Atlantic of the
United States and Western Europe then
it's even less the case that there's a
global crisis after all in Asia
developing Asia meaning India China
Southeast Asia economic growth rates are
at unprecedented lehigh levels by
historical comparison China has been
growing as you know at a rate of about
10 percent per year for more than three
decades that means a doubling every
seven years and even through recent
years China's economic growth is right
now around 8 percent per year
India a bit less other countries in Asia
varying around 6% and in some cases
higher the world economic growth is
about four to four and a half
per year which means the whole world
economy is doubling roughly every 18 to
20 years right now which is astounding
for a world of seven billion people and
an average income worldwide of about
$10,000 per capita so a 70 trillion
dollar world economy experiencing a
doubling every generation or even less
I've been attending the g20 meetings
each one is part of the delegation of
the secretary-general and it's a very
odd feeling you know because most of the
g20 from Brazil to China to India and
elsewhere look on and say crisis what
what global crisis exactly are you
talking about oh you mean the eurozone
crisis or the u.s. crisis well that's
different that's not a global economic
crisis so I think we need to gain some
perspective of why this peculiar
divergence in perspective is happening
and the reason is a remarkable
convergence in economics and that is
that the developing countries which we
now call the emerging markets are
achieving robust economic progress by
leapfrogging technologies and high
saving rates and making a tremendous
amount of economic progress and
narrowing the gaps with the richer
countries China was 1 or 2 percent of
the world income when Dunc shopping
through the country's borders open to
globalization and it's now about 11%
compared to the u.s. 18% which is down
from about 24 25 percent a generation
ago and at least plausible
extrapolations of the IMF say that the
two countries will meet somewhere around
2016 at about 16 percent each of the
world economy so there is a kind of
convert
going on and we feel it in geopolitics
as well as in economics now my view is
that this has had a profound effect on
the US and on part of the u.s. because
it's also true we don't have even a
general economic crisis in the United
States we don't have a Great Depression
or even anything close to it for college
students not students sorry for college
grads while the labor market is soft
compared to three or four years ago the
unemployment rate for those with the
bachelor's degree or higher is about 4%
it's up a little bit but the income
levels of people probably most of us
here that are fortunate to have a good
education and have had good support has
been very strong for the last 20 years
what's happened is that under the
dynamics of globalization it's really
the bottom half of our society that has
experienced a remarkable collapse the
neighborhood factory is no longer there
the high school diploma followed by the
manufacturing job no longer exists in
this country and so what used to be the
pathway to the middle class a high
school diploma and a job in the local
manufacturing firm that disappeared and
so we have also a divergence even within
the US of a remarkably successful top of
the income distribution there now-fabled
1% and a crisis of the bottom 50% and a
quite serious crisis of the bottom 50%
now let me add just a couple of other
quick elements to that and then turn to
implications as I see them first this
remarkable overall global economic
development is bringing a perilous
environmental crisis with it the rise of
China is certainly the most rapid drum
maduk astounding reduction of poverty in
world history but it is also the most
astounding increase of greenhouse gas
emissions of climate change inducing
effects therefore of environmental
catastrophe within China itself that is
part of this we have worldwide a
deepening and profound environmental
crisis that is recognized everywhere
except the editorial page of The Wall
Street Journal and it's getting worse
and it's getting and it is unattended
too we also have continuing upheaval not
only because globalization has shifted
worldwide jobs and labor market
competition in absolutely unprecedented
ways hugely to the detriment of lower
skilled workers and to the benefit of
those with capital who can now invest
all over the world in even more
profitable ventures but it is our world
is under unprecedented flux because of a
true absolutely astounding revolution of
information technology which is changing
the nature of jobs everywhere in almost
every sector it is the ultimate
disruptive technology of our time this
leads me finally to the policy
implications as I see them and I find
myself close to Ned Phelps on a lot of
the observations we need activist
government to help us steer through
these challenges because government is
critical for infrastructure for skills
for education for support for science
for support for the upstream
technologies of change in the future and
it's of course vital to help those who
otherwise will not be able to get a
foothold and that is a remarkable 50% of
our society right now living in
low-income households this is the class
of the middle class in America and we
need government to help face this
question so the children can get through
school can get a college education but
even today only 1/3 of our kids finish a
bachelor's degree and only 11% of
Hispanic young men aged 25 to 29 have a
BA and this is the catastrophe of social
and equality in this country government
needs to help but is not helping right
now the societies that are working are
the ones that tax themselves adequately
so that the public goods can be provided
so that every child can get decent
preschool public education and then
through higher education if they needed
so that infrastructure can be modernized
so that energy systems can move to a
low-carbon economy so that we can get
out of the various traps that we're in
and that we can address the realities of
the deep profound challenges of
globalization America's fundamental
problem in my opinion is that since
Ronald Reagan came to office January 20
1981 and declared the fateful words the
government is not the solution to our
problems government is the problem
we have been on more than a 30-year jag
of dismantling the very means to address
the challenges that we face as a society
and I'll and I'll close ladies and
gentlemen with one piece of unfortunate
reality for us and this to my mind is
the is the bottom line it's literally
the bottom line and if you want to find
the bottom line go to OMB gov that's
where you find the budget and click on
budget and then click on summary tables
at the bottom of the budget and then go
to table S - 6 and I say it because a
little geeky but if you want to find out
the ultimate deep trend that we're on it
is in that table of the Obama budget
since we do not tax ourselves we are
squeezing government to the breaking
point even President Obama who gives
wonderful speeches about the need to
invest in the future does not match
those fantastic speeches with the
funding to actually do that and the line
that is most important is what's called
the non-security discretionary budget of
the u.s. this is where will you find
education job training infrastructure
energy Science and Technology
Environmental Protection Agency Small
Business Administration federal land
management everything except the
military and the transfer payments now
that used to be between 5 & 6 percent of
national income in the 1970s then came
Reagan and he took it down to three
percent for that combined vital function
of government for 30 years reaganomics
has ruled didn't matter Democrats and
Republicans three percent with small
variations no change remember so many I
won't go into I don't have time for the
details maybe in the in the discussion
but where are we now because of rising
debt service payments because of an
aging population because of higher
health care costs and because of this
relentless tax cutting even that our
president is pushing still that
discretionary line in the President's
budget will fall from 3.1 percent of
national income down to 1.8 percent of
national income in the year 2020 we are
dismantling the very means to address
the needs of our society thank you
and so George Soros I'm not in
disagreement with your conclusions but I
should like to take issue with your
premise namely that there is no global
crisis because that's the way we can
have a good discussion so
so I I do think we are in a global
crisis that our global financial system
is not functioning the way supposed to
and that the financial markets are
actually proactively paralyzed by the
degree of uncertainty which is a measure
of the crisis but I think that the
crisis is very deep-seated and to to
understand its nature I would actually
like to start off at the deep end I
contend that mankind's ability to
understand and to control nature is much
greater than its ability to understand
human affairs and to govern itself and
that disparity has been growing and it
has now reached disturbing proportions
in recent years and that is actually at
the core of the crisis I attribute that
disparity to a fundamental difference
between the natural and Social Sciences
the Natural Sciences deal with facts
that unfold independently of the
scientific statements that are made
above them the facts therefore serve as
an independent criterion by which the
truth or validity of the statements can
be judged and that is what has enabled
natural science to produce such amazing
results
by contrast the facts that formed the
subject matter of the social sciences
are produced by thinking participants
and these agents think very differently
from natural scientists they don't have
an independent criterion by which they
can judge the validity of their views
therefore they base their decisions not
on knowledge but on an inherently under
imperfect understanding of of the facts
and their imperfect understanding
introduce the element of uncertainty
into the course of events that is absent
in the Natural Sciences and interferes
with the ability of the Social Sciences
to produce comparable results economics
which became the most influential of the
Social Sciences so to escape this
inferior status by taking an axiomatic
approach similar to Euclid's geometry
but you teach axioms resembled reality
very closely the axioms of the efficient
market hypothesis the distorted reality
quite substantially there because they
eliminated the uncertainty caused by
imperfect understanding and that
uncertainty today is is absolutely
dominating our lives
this has far-reaching consequences
exactly because economic economics
became so influential a false
interpretation of financial markets led
to the progressive dismantling of
regulations and firewalls
this caused one financial crisis after
and that another and the wife widespread
use of risk management methods and
synthetic financial instruments like
CEOs and CBS which were based on
unrealistic assumptions greatly
aggravated the impact of these crises
the banks bankruptcy of Lehman Brothers
in October 2008 started a meltdown that
was prevented only by putting markets on
artificial life support and they are not
yet back to normal now there is a one
which spread recognition that the
efficient market hypothesis has failed
there have been many other instances in
Naturals are in actual science when a
prevailing paradigm was the discarded
but none have had such profound
practical consequences on our daily
lives and even in the present case there
is very little understanding how
deep-seated the failure is in my view
economic theory must abandon its
pretense to be like a natural science
and come to terms with the uncertainty
that is inherent in the subject matter
and that will require a fundamental
rethinking of the methods and criteria
that govern it
as a science I have done some of the
rethinking I've developed a conceptual
framework based on the thing
of failed ability and reflexivity but I
have very little company even among my
fellow speakers who are actually closer
to my view than most other economies so
we should have plenty to talk about
thank you well
but I think we do have plenty to talk
about because there is a there seems a
even if we accept that that economics
does have some factual or systemic basis
there is does seem a disagreement about
the kinds and depths and extent of
government action that seem appropriate
in the current situation and and
therefore I and Paul everyone has
mentioned the lack of some kinds of
stimulus everyone has mentioned the lack
of some kind of government investment
everyone has mentioned the need for some
kind of intervention but the different
kinds of intervention that close more
closely we listen we listen seem quite
distinguishable so I would like to ask
Paul about what more specifically does
he think is lacking in the way of
intervention okay so I'm the Keynesian
on this panel I think that we I agree
with what the I mean I agree with Jeff
very much on the the savaging or our
long-run stuff but and we should be
doing much more on that but we also have
an immediate problem which is a very
large unemployment large numbers of
workers who could be employed who should
be employed and the government should be
playing a large role in pumping up
demand right now Ned calls this crude
Keynesianism which is a fairly common
thing I've been saying that the next guy
who calls me crew and I'm going to haul
them out and punch him in the snot snot
it's it's it's it's it's very a lot of
intellectual work has gone into into the
kinds of things I'm saying I may state
them are pretty
you know try to put them in plain
English but there's people who have very
very well thought economic models and
there is actually this happens to be a
golden age for macroeconomic research
terrible times often are and and there's
wonderful work being done now assessing
the effects of government spending and
so on and it's coming at very Keynesian
there's a lot of new work that that
basically says that basically says that
if only the government would be spending
more right now we would be in much much
better shape and and that and it sounds
very wise as I said at the beginning it
sounds very wise and judicious to say
well there are no short resolutions it's
totally wrong it's actually it but then
we have an overwhelmingly a short-run
problem right now that could be solved
in two years if only we had the
political will and the intellectual
clarity unfortunately both of those are
sorely lacking actually we don't want a
factual I want maybe just a couple of
factual points then I want to say
something about about Greece net says
it's common knowledge that we've had an
explosion of entitlements in recent
years I guess I don't share that common
knowledge my knowledge is that there's
been an explosion of unemployment
benefits substantial growth of food
stamps and considerable growth of
Medicaid in recent years and those are
not policy decisions that's not an
expansion of the safety net it's just
that there are more people falling into
the net there's these dis expansion that
you see in the last few years is
entirely a consequence of this terrible
economic slump not the result of
government suddenly deciding that it's
going to throw out a lot more benefits
take out those and you really don't see
any anything big happening in recent
years so that I think that's an
important point to make Jeff says that
it's the bottom half that's hurting and
that the highly educated are doing okay
not according to my read the census of a
Fed has been doing some work on the
what's happening to recent college
graduates and yes of course I mean other
things equal college graduates gonna be
better off with someone who isn't a
college graduate but it's terrible it's
a it's a catastrophic fall and on in the
employment rates not so much
unemployment but the but the French who
are employed has dropped sharply wages
of recent college graduates have dropped
very sharply probably
not because the wages that college
graduates that you employ a college
graduate for have fallen but rather that
large numbers of recent college
graduates are working as baristas or
whatever but they cannot have to find
jobs that make use of their skills and
we have a fair body of economic research
if you want to ask you know if somebody
graduates into this bad job the labor
market and does not initially get the
job that she or he could should be
getting given given a training how long
does it take to recover from that and
the answer is River people young people
graduating from college right now will
be scarred there their careers will be
scarred for the rest of their lives so
this is a very broadly shared crisis
within the United States if you look at
it there there is no substantial
occupational or educational group that
has not been really a hard hit it's not
the case that it's only the bottom half
of the population within Europe yeah it
is true that Germany is floating along
pretty well although let's ask I'm not
sure that will have that same story next
year some other countries are floating
on Germany is is floating along pretty
well because it's running an enormous
trade surplus which is the the flipside
of the large trade deficits being
running so the Europe and what the
Germans tell you is basically they say
why shouldn't everybody be like us so
should we doll run gigantic trade
surplus that's not essentially just
talking to somebody from NASA this
afternoon and asking about the where
we're gonna find the planet we're going
to export too so I don't think you
really want to think of Europe as being
a single economy like the United States
it doesn't have a single government
which is their tragedy but if you look
at the European economy as a whole it's
doing somewhat worse than the United
States it's it's it's it's wrong to pick
it out none of us said much about Greece
and that's a good thing because I've
been protesting for quite a while about
what I've been calling the hell in the
hellenization of our discourse here
everybody talks about Greece and says
and and views Greece as the great
example of what's going wrong Greece is
pretty much in a class by itself
Portugal a little bit but none of the
other even within the crisis countries
in Europe none of the others has a
crisis where government irresponsibility
was a large share of how they got into
the crisis look at Spain and you see
that it was a monstrous private-sector
overreach a monstrous housing bubble
Spanish government was running budget
surpluses on
the crisis came into the crisis with
with low debt Italy for everything we
say about it yes they have a large debt
which is an inheritance of very
irresponsible policies quite a while ago
but they were steadily reducing that
debt relative to GDP until the crisis
hit so this is this is not Greece is a
terrible motivating example it's
unfortunately because of the underlying
weakness of the European situation if
Greece blows up which seems extremely
likely then it will probably have
contagion effects but do not think of
Greece as being a role model for what's
gone wrong elsewhere well I still think
I know that Ned wants reply and I think
we're still in search of quite specific
kinds of intervention because okay the
one thing Jeff talks about you know
cutbacks but if you want to look at
something right now over the past four
years we've had a roughly three percent
decline in state and local government
deployment which is mostly
schoolteachers being fired of course
given population growth we should have
had something like a 4% increase instead
so if you want a starting thing there's
something we should reverses provide
money to those local governments the
school district so they can rehire all
those school teachers they delay well
I'm not I'm not sure that's what Ned has
in Maya so I really welcome this
opportunity to chat with Paul he's very
elusive wait I haven't run into him in
about two years at that time we had the
same diagram up on the blackboard but it
hasn't been the same since since well I
agree with everything Paul said about
Greece I was making over similar points
that Greeks Greece is totally
unrepresentative of what's going on
Italy France in America sorry to say and
I don't want to drone on obsessively
about the D word is it the D word though
it's C word
C are you d
but let me say if we were having a
textbook Keynes in slump we would have
seen maybe not outright deflation
falling price level but we would have at
least seen a heck of a lot of
disinflation a big decline in the rate
of inflation we haven't seen that now we
will probably can argue the details all
night but I think broadly speaking it's
fair to say that we have not had
anything like the marked disinflation
that we would have had if our problems
were in essence coming to us through
monetary mechanisms and so-called
effective or aggregate demand the second
paul refers to econometrics work which I
haven't seen which shows the importance
of government expenditures for
employment I can't help but have the
feeling that there's a bit of trading
here on on the obvious sure if if the
government if somewhere in the public
sector somebody fires if somebody gets
fired the world is full of frictions and
that person goes into the unemployment
pool he doesn't instantaneously get
employed by the economy as a whole
thanks to some miraculous auctioneer who
somehow been able to figure out who
should go where thanks to some option
err so of course there are short-run
effects when there's a contraction of
government expenditures but lots of us
in the economics profession have monal
models not everyday not exclusively but
lots of us do have some models that
don't have money in them and you know
what if government expenditures drops
there's that there's
at least momentarily an increase of
unemployment so that this doesn't
establish the validity of the whole
Keynesian opera apparatus just to say
that there are some of some some effects
of shocks to government expenditure
unemployment and I guess I guess I've
made both points that I wanted to make
here so I'll stop here thank you hi now
I know that listening we had heard about
this 50% who now Paul has added to that
50% a further decline in not only among
the manufactured manufacturing draws but
through higher levels of the economy and
it seems to me this that is something
that you might want to respond to sure I
think that the gist of what I'm
suggesting is that we have a lot of
investment to do whether it's and skills
or technology or infrastructure but that
the idea that we can find solutions to
these instantaneously Paul mocks this
all Grubb my beard I think is wrong we
have what we are not doing in this
country is thinking beyond a 1 year or
two your time horizon what passes for
stimulus now is tax cuts a one-year
payroll tax cut or extending the Bush
era tax cuts or half of the original
stimulus was tax cuts and nothing in the
government's actions for the last three
years sadly has been for the longer term
and so what we've ended up with over
this pure
is an explosion of debt but very little
to show for it over the longer term and
that's why we see the prospect in future
years of actual shrinkage in the core
areas where we need to take better
action we're ending up with less
government not more we're ending up with
our tax base being further decimated
we're ending up without infrastructure
the President himself acknowledged so it
turned out there were no shovel ready
projects after all and there weren't
because a modern society in the 21st
century cannot build a national
infrastructure on shovels it's
impossible we need plans we need
decade-long investments we need to think
in the medium-term we need an
expenditure pathway which is viable but
instead we get year-to-year
improvisation that passes for some kind
of stimulus and the implications of this
for us if it does any good it's unclear
but what it in the even in the
short-term but it's not doing any
problem solving for the long-term what
shocks me and worries me about our
country right now is our inability to
think longer term our political system
is relentless there is no day that is in
a campaign no matter when there is no
decision that we've even come down to
two-month policymaking extend the tax
cuts for two months or for six months
it's it's completely absurd and we face
problems of a new energy system here we
have antiquated infrastructure that's
more than 50 years old any of us
traveling abroad in a so-called
developing country sees the gleaming
infrastructure and then comes back to
JFK
or elsewhere and we know what we're
really facing in this country right now
we're not doing anything anything ladies
and gentlemen to solve this there's no
budget revenues there's no longer term
plans the so-called Jobs Act is one
year's budget mm fiscal 2013 that's a
jobs plan that's no jobs plan that is an
election year platform and we need
something more how are we gonna graduate
40 or 50 percent of our kids through the
bachelors degree how are we going to get
the skills met when the manufacturing
sector is saying that they can't even
fill six or seven hundred thousand jobs
of skilled craftsmen of technically
trained workers and they're applying for
h-1b visas to try to hire foreign
workers to fill these positions because
our kids are not getting through school
and they're not getting the training
that they need they're going in in
fairly large numbers in the first year
of college and then dropping out in very
large numbers because they can't meet
tuition so I think that the point that
I'm emphasizing is we need to take a
longer term we believe in activist
government all of us but you do have to
pay for it and that means understanding
we have to pay taxes and we have to have
the revenues in order to be able to
carry out the longer-term investments we
need and we are not going to solve the
problems except if we had an adequate
time horizon to think them through and
to put a real public investment strategy
in these various areas final thought I
want to just agree with George and not
and say that I don't disagree with you
on a broken financial system and the
points you emphasize you have taught us
and proved it also about the inherent
nature of financial instability a lot of
the this is
and it is all a reason to try to get our
financial sector back under regulation
because the biggest damage we did was
the repeal of glass-steagall the lack of
and how is it that the author of that it
seems possibly to be named the next
World Bank president you tell me that
puzzle of American accountability I
Larry Summers I don't get it but but
this is how weird this country is every
day there's criminality on Wall Street
new finds new evidence of the
misbehavior that all this deregulation
made possible and encouraged in fact and
there's just no accountability
whatsoever and for it
I very much looking forward to George
having some comment about these
different ranges of government
yeah government failure government need
for stimulus need for intervention need
for regulation I wonder what your own
view is of government role probably all
of us agree on the need for an activist
government but I think we represent at
this point a minority in the country
because I think the the idea that
government can't do anything right that
that the government is wasteful that
everything is the fault of government
has gained the upper hand it has been
extremely well promoted I'm full of
admiration for the verge myths and they
the manipulators who have done it is not
only money there is also a lot of talent
in communication
which seems to be lacking on the other
side on our side but it has been very
effective and it's a kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy
because if you have a government devoted
to proving how but that government can't
do everything right and the government
you know then it's relatively easy to
prove it so so this is what we are up
against and while you are right Jeff
about saying that well we have to take a
long view and unfortunately the
four-year election cycle does lead to
short-term thinking and also the
quarterly reporting in corporations lead
to short-term thinking in in the private
sector but it's not just a short and a
long term there is a more fundamental
division now and there is a something
has gone quite significantly wrong in
the political system when you have two
parties more interested in defeating the
other then in following policies that
will benefit the country
and right now I think you have a
Republican or a conservative
conservative message which is more
interested in cutting government
spending but then in maintaining the
economy because by insisting on
balancing the budget and avoiding any
new taxes and including in new taxes
they avoid the elimination of the tax
loopholes that's considered new taxes
right with that there's only one way to
go and that is to cut services and of
course that Dunn's a big economic
activity it says it's a fiscal
constraint on the economy well now I
think we've arrived at a rather
difficult point because we have a we've
come down to the political core of the
economic analysis that experts have been
making and I think we have time for some
questions from the audience about those
matters now one person who is here and
who is a contributor the New York Review
and whose analyses have been
particularly accused I'd like to call on
to oppose the first question and that's
Jeff Madrick now being after he poses
the question we can have other questions
from the audience but I want to make two
cautionary notes please keep any
questions brief please avoid explanatory
hortatory statements and please make
sure that everything is put in the forum
of a clear question because if it's not
we'll pass on to someone who does have a
question and now I hope Jeff Madrick is
here
and I hope he'll ask a question Bob
thank you after that exhortation maybe I
should sit down but in any case thank
you Bob thank the panelists for an
excellent presentation and one that
wasn't entirely sparks free I think I
probably speak for almost everyone in
this audience and my own enthusiasm for
public investment to the extent I write
about it I've been writing about it for
a long time but the issue is how do we
get from where we are today
which I do think is a precarious
position to public investment down the
road and I'd like to bring us a little
bit to the here and now and ask you this
question can the US government survive
what's going to be at best a model can
the US economy survive what's at best
going to be a modest economic stimulus
and can it survive a crisis in Europe we
haven't talked about that will Greece
lead to serious recession in Europe and
what will be the consequences for the US
economy because if we slide into another
recession we're not going to get to the
public investment the Jeffrey Sachs is
talking about so I throw that open to
the panel what are the odds of recession
and crisis in Europe having serious
fallout in the US I think that's a good
question and I think we there may be
some responsive he's talking about the
possibility of another recession so if
I'm on first probability of a European
recession I would say 100% cuz it's
already started and a question of how
severe that's less clear let's say
something optimistic I'm not feeling too
well so let me say something optimistic
if it doesn't turn into a full-blown
financial crisis the impact on us is a
lot less than people imagine the actual
sort of direct trade linkages we all
talk about global etcetera but we only
export about two and a half percent of
u.s. GDP to Europe so even a fairly
serious slump in Europe in terms of the
actual impact via exports it's not all
that big it's perfectly possible that
whatever
in Europe and continuing modest recovery
in the United States if it turns into a
Lehman style event all bets are off but
I think that that's there are a lot of
reasons to be very very upset about
what's happening in Europe among other
things because Europe is it's not just
economics it's politics the European
project which is democracy and peace has
to succeed or the world is a much worse
place but I'm not I'm actually a lot
less scared about the direct economic
impact then a lot of people are which
probably famous last words that I'm fond
of making the point that when there's
some weakening somewhere in the world
that has a bright side as well as a dark
side for the rest of the world and that
is then that comes from the fact that
when the weakness in in some part of the
world lowers world real interest rates
and that's good for stock markets
businesses appetites for investment and
so forth I remember I was in Hong Kong
one day talking in an academic way about
this interest rate Channel from one
country to another and and the news came
on the the news came in that there was
some weakening of the US economy in a
quarterly report the Hong Kong stock
market took off stock prices jumped way
up so it the public doesn't understand
that the linkages between say Europe and
America are very complex and we can't be
all that sure how things will come out
very quickly
I think what Paul mentioned is worth
underscoring that when mario draghi
came into the european central bank and
very deftly increased liquidity it
changed the perspective from what was
unmitigated disaster and a
self-fulfilling crisis over the cliff to
what is a very painful period for greece
but not a catastrophe even for the other
countries of of southern Europe so I
think the European situation while still
very unpredictable largely because
German German economic policymaking for
the eurozone is so bad that we can't
predict that Germany will guide anything
properly in the end it's just
ideologically driven manifestly not
looking at reality right now but Mario
Draghi has the most important job by far
in Europe and that is the European
Central Bank and he's doing what is
necessary there to stop the
self-fulfilling collapse and it's
changed dramatically the seen over the
last few weeks and that's why the the
mood is brighter it's why Spain and
Italy suddenly can sell debt again and I
think this is a reason for optimism is
showing spontaneous spontaneous strength
but it is basically manufacturing
interesting and it's due to the the
shale shale gas now shale oil which is
much much cheaper in the United States
them elsewhere it's shale gas is 250
cubic feet in America and $18 in Asia I
won't go into the problems of pollution
I'd be interested in reading the article
in The New York Review of Books from
everything I found out so far the
property pollution problems even if they
are not necessarily currently contained
could be contained by regulation and so
that's a big boon for for America and
also wages which have not risen now for
several years have made us competitive
so exports are increasing now I think
that the there will be a fiscal drag on
the recovery and as I mentioned the we
attempt to try to do too
put a brake on on the recovery it will
affect this year's performance I think I
think as far as Europe is concerned the
the mario draghi did relieve the credit
crunch which was really beginning to
hurt the European economy so that's a
very important relief now there are
still problems of Greece and and etc but
the immediate downward pressure is
relief and interestingly you have a
counter positive influence and the
global economy from China because China
is in a period of transition the new new
group is taking over later this year or
next year and they are determined to
avoid a social unrest during experience
so they are now stimulating but the
interesting thing is that actually China
is facing a need to really to really
jiggle its growth model it cannot
maintain the current rate because it's
all based on exports and and
infrastructure investments and only one
third of the economy is now consumption
so even if you move over to stimulating
consumption assimilating one by the
other two-thirds
has to diminish will bring about a
slowdown in the growth date but that
will only come next year so but this
year I think we be the stimulus Chinese
stimulus will help the global economy so
the outlook is mix well I want to thank
our panelists with some very sharp and
Susan now we have time for another
question and we had one from that side
so I think we should have one from this
side thank you um I worked for two years
as a quant at a hedge fund actually with
Larry Summers I left to work in risk
management I did things like I do speak
louder yes I worked at a hedge fund with
Larry Summers during the credit crisis I
left to do risk management and I did
credit default swap modeling for example
in 2009 to 2011 and I finally left
disgusted with the whole thing I've
heard this sort of come up tangentially
and everything you guys have said but
one of the things that I can't help
think about the credit crisis and the
financial crisis is that what's
different about it from the previous the
Great Depression is the complexity of
the system itself and you know for
example I think we mentioned the
glass-steagall was revoked but actually
it was revoked when it was essentially
already moot because the shadow banking
system had had gone around the rules we
have a Volcker rule that's coming the
new regulation the Volcker Rule has been
essentially written by the lobbyists and
the reason that written by the lobbyists
is because the politicians and the SEC
do not understand the financial system
I'm sorry
you are making an exposition yeah yeah
but we haven't heard a question the
question is how are we going to deal
with the complexity if we give money and
it just goes to the people who are
fixing the system how is that gonna help
I'd like to understand how we're going
to deal
if making it a simpler system that that
sort of was inspired by Paul Volcker to
some extent and by an even earlier
literature on narrow banking and in
recent times
Ammar bday has taken up the case and the
the bidets position is yeah too much
complexity so we've got to simplify
we've got to simplify the commercial
banks so they do one thing
they take the people retail deposits
from households and in invest them in in
in in routine familiar assets and then
you have some hedge funds they do some
more adventurous things but they're
small and they're also simple so you get
a kind of division of function you don't
have behemoths who do 17 different
things before breakfast you you have so
at least you get greater clarity greater
transparency on what's going on it
should be much easier to regulate such a
system but you got to restructure you
can't just take the existing structure
and say okay we're gonna regulate it now
I have a quick take your dodd-frank
probably too deep into the weeds all
together but dodd-frank is a is not a
stupid bill Barney Frank is not a stupid
man and and it don't it gives this
problem basically by giving the
financial stability Oversight Council a
lot of ability to crack down on what
things might be as a dangerous
institution so that it can designate
something as a strategically important
institution without that being defined
it's a pornography standard supposed to
know it when you see it which i think is
at least doesn't and my initial reaction
was this is probably not going to work
nothing would be so classified but that
the early read is that this is actually
exerting a kind of a chilling effect on
these complex out-of-control
institutions because people are afraid
they might be so classified and in that
case it might work the thing that
worries me most about it is judgemental
means it relies on the quality and
honesty and integrity of the people in
the top positions and so this might work
the current management when president
Santorum appoints were on : legislation
that complexity will be greatly reduced
unfortunately unfortunately citizens
united and all the other that we are
going the opposite direction so bad
government has become a self-fulfilling
prophecy allow very quickly I think
there are four things that I would also
mention in addition to the
simplification one is corporate boards
that have legal responsibilities and
that are held accountable second
leverage we know was the is is the
ultimate elixir of this explosive risk
third it was known at the end of the
1990s why regulation was needed in the
derivatives market
Larry fought it fought it very hard but
it wasn't a mystery that this was needed
and forth
now that we've seen wreckin relentless
law breaking on Wall Street relentless
fraud in during this financial crisis
there has been no accountability
whatsoever yet
so this isn't just risk-taking this is
absolute financial fraud by every Markie
firm knowingly gaming the system and we
have one fine after another but it's
being paid by the shareholders the CEOs
are remaining in place there is no
criminal investigation though president
obama finally said maybe there ought to
be maybe but not so evident yet so i
think that it's not beyond us we've been
through this kind of financial crisis
before and twice our country was rescued
by a roosevelt from the Gilded Age and
from the Great Depression so maybe a
third Roosevelt good idea because there
is criminality there always has been
Financial Wall Street but it's not it's
not endemic and and it's not the
criminality that's causing the problems
it's it's bad governance it's it's you
know it's a impunity don't it's easy to
look for but I think it's important and
notable that Goldman Citigroup Bank of
America others teamed up teamed up with
hedge funds to sell of knowing toxic
assets to their own clients knowing that
they were designed to fail and that now
they're paying fines on them of several
hundred million dollars each but these
were decisions taken by senior senior
bankers many of whom are still in place
still receiving still receiving their
bonuses and compensation and some CEOs
remaining and this is this is financial
fraud as far as I'm concerned and as far
as the SEC is concerned
I don't want to you know go overboard
certainly a defending lawsuit because
I'm the critical voice yes but I think
this emphasis on individual wrongdoing
is the wrong emphasis it's systemic and
and even though you had those excesses
deliberately created the CEOs that you
know that were designed to fail dummy if
the fact that you have CEOs and that
they were used the way they were and yet
CEOs squared that should not have been
allowed by the regulator's of course of
course I agree but there are several
lines of defense against this and when
we arrive at a situation where this tiny
little outfit AIG financial products is
writing unbelievable sums of CD asses of
credit default swaps with no backing
whatsoever
bringing helping to bring the whole
financial system to a crash at the end
and then and then and then Larry Summers
says we're a country of law we have to
pay them their bonuses still how are we
ever going to get it under control if
there isn't accountability ultimately
well I think George would agree that
accountability I think we have we can
have one question and I think it should
come from this side thank you first of
all for taking questions it seems that a
concern over lack of us stimulus or
spending is common to some of the
package that it seems that a stimulant
our concern over lack of us stimulants
or
bending is common to some of the
panelists tonight but it also seems that
some skepticism about the efficiency of
the US government spending is also a
reasonable are there any policy changes
that the panelists would recommend that
might enhance the confidence of citizens
and government spending as a means of
additionally galvanizing political will
around that kind of spending thank you
yes what is your question
yep how to change if you think policy is
to make people more friendly to
government spending all right yeah I
guess all right alphabetical yeah you
know I would say that a lot of what we
need to do is is simply try to get
across a little bit we we spend our
politicians spent so much time trashing
government that people don't have an
idea of the good things government does
so I mention actually this morning in
The Times the 44 percent of Social
Security recipients say that they do not
benefit from any government program 40
percent of Medicare recipients people
when people think you talk about
government workers they know you know
when they imagine that we're talking
about you know drones and in vast
offices doing nothing but if you want to
think who is the typical government
worker
it's a schoolteacher and and in fact
we've seen the 500 thousand government
workers five hundred thousand person
reduction in the government workforce
including it's mostly coming in the
state and local level and and three
hundred thousand of that the
schoolteachers so I think a lot of it is
not that we have a government that does
badly but that we have people who trash
it and of course you know this is gonna
be bad there could be bad investments
bad decisions made in government no
that's not unique to government does
anybody read Dilbert I mean it's a so so
I think the me of course we want improve
but I think the problem is really not
what the government
problem is with the way our political
system was portrays government so I
think just because our time is short and
we want the audience to have a chance we
can have a question from either side
thanks thanks so I've been listening and
I heard Jeff Sachs professor Sachs say
that the reason of a big reason for the
lack of economic growth in the long term
is because we don't tax enough and I
think Paul Krugman also mentioned in an
earlier piece that tax rate shouldn't
just go to the bush administer do with
how you would explain the success of
countries like Hong Kong and Singapore
they have a maximum tax rate of 15 or 20
percent on income no taxes on capital
gains or investment and free sorry and
free trade and stable regulatory
environment so don't you attribute any
of the success to those two states which
have a higher per capita GDP income than
even the United States and just 50 or 60
years ago where fishing villages - - you
know regulatory policies that are fair
low and low taxes on investment and low
tax rates generally Thanks so anywhere
you would say why don't we have a flat
tax is that your the kind of thing you
you are getting at I my question is
don't you think that there's any benefit
to lower tax rates free trade and a
stable regulatory environment because it
seems like the general consensus on this
in this panel has been that we need more
regulation higher taxes you know at an
even higher rate than we're in the case
in the 90s and that's the main reason
for a lack of long term economic growth
or even short term recovery from this
financial crisis I think this is a good
question on which to end because it
represents a very shall I save current
form of thinking and that is very
implicated in our current political
situation so well it would be worth
having some comment on it
have a try at that well Singapore is not
the is not the innovative kind of
economy that the British economy was
over much of the 19th century and that
the American economy was from let's say
the 1830s right up through most of the
1960s Singapore is is swimming in the
slipstream of a lot of big players
who've been doing the heavy lifting and
inner innovation for a long time you
can't possibly say that the trouble
United States is that it's not like
Singapore it just doesn't make sense it
won't compute of course in some sort of
stationary state when there's no when
there no projects left to do and we have
perfect knowledge and we're all kind of
brain dead from lack of use then we
could have very low tax rates but we're
in a very changing world lots of
challenges and lots of opportunities for
innovation that's for sure with all
those mines now working in the
commercial business sectors around the
world for sure we're going to have an
immense amount of new ideas and new
products coming up so we're going to
want to have an economy in America
that's able to to play the game that is
able to take advantage of this new
climate for innovation but right now we
don't have a financial sector that's
serving innovation we don't have an
education system that's providing young
people with any kind of mathematics or
languages that might be necessary in at
many
avant-garde firms we don't even have a
rhetoric anymore of discovery and
challenge and change and and this
exploration it's it's it's now they talk
about the American Dream as if it was
having it having a house preferably one
you own and why that that should be that
the American Dream is is beyond me used
to be that the American dream was to
make a mark to do something to do
something you would be proud of and and
and and to have to have a to have the
involvement and and the challenge and
that's what we have to get back to we
don't want to be look more like
Singapore when I want to say you don't
have something to say yeah let me just
say I don't want to get into a debate
about Singapore and Hong Kong I just
want to say that you're picking some
small faraway country of which we know
nothing value there and saying oh that's
the role model that that's a common game
in u.s. debate which which relies
especially on the fact that so many of
us so know so little if you may remember
during the no Social Security debate all
of a sudden we had everybody talking
about the wonders of slayin retirement
system and no it turned out that you'll
annotate it but anyway it was you know
we don't know so so this is this is no
way to make the argument the question
you want to ask is how is the United
States going to pay for the things it
wants to do and if it's if you're
willing to say look I'm gonna have a
political platform then we're gonna
abolish Medicare or Social Security and
Medicaid and all of that and then we can
have a really low rate of taxes fine but
no one is making that case not really no
one's winning elections on that case
it's our Mitt Romney responded to the
latest Obama budget by saying President
President Obama is failing to take on
the problem of entitlements and
furthermore he's the first president to
ever propose cuts in Medicare Briony so
the
what we're talking about taxes because
we need to actually pay for what it is
we want yeah I want to link the both of
those questions and also follow up on
Ned's point the government together with
the private sector in complicated
complex ways played a crucial role in
the age of computers of course in
internet which started as a Department
of Defense project in genomics in space
science in many of the absolute crucial
world changers that were crucial for our
economy as well as for our well-being
none of this happened overnight
all of it required some foresight and
some extended national effort President
Kennedy in 1961 did not say we will put
a man on the moon and bring bring him
safely back to earth by the next
election
he gave NASA a full decade to do it he
said by the end of this decade when's
the last time we've taken on a national
project in recent years that extends
beyond the stimulus beyond the next year
beyond one year at a time we're not
doing it anymore so if we want effective
government we have to think ahead we
have to actually put out timelines we
have to actually put out numbers that
extend over several years we actually
have to have and I it's one of the most
hated words in the American political
economic lexicon we actually have to
have a plan once in a while for what we
want to do not a central planned economy
but a plan for what our energy system
might look like what our rail and road
network might look like and so board
and I can tell you they don't do it
anywhere in government right now they're
scared to death to write down any
planning at all because they don't want
to be held hostage to it because of the
lobbying because the publicity whatever
it is there are no plans being made on
any crucial objectives for our country
right now and that's why the government
isn't able to function adequately and
that's why we're going around in circles
ladies and gentlemen I want to say we're
each and going beyond 8 o'clock
and I think we've hadded I want to thank
our panelists
and
I think we they a useful a very useful
discussion of what we might call the
different phases of intervention and a
very grateful to our people and all I
can say is to be continued thank you
very much
is there an on